[Music]
you got to be a certain type of person
to get into flying without an engine
factor able to leave the ground leave
everything behind fly through the skies
on nylon and strings is exceptional
[Music]
the rat race is a seven day long
paragliding competition with 200
participants that also serves as the
u.s. national airline championship my
name is Nick Reese I'm a professional
paraglider pilot paragliding race is
very similar to a sailboat race they
race around buoys we raise around
several different GPS coordinates that
we have to hit along the way each
morning the race course is determined by
the weather for that day and of course
typically ranges from forty to seventy
miles long the first person to finish
the course every day two thousand points
if someone's five seconds back they get
nine ninety five and so on and so forth
and then at seven days you add up all
your scores together and whoever has the
most points wins
I grew up in Long Island in a suburb
close to New York City I went to Beloit
College in Wisconsin and after that I
returned to Manhattan take a job at a PR
firm my second day of work was September
11th 2001 so I was walking to work I saw
the first plane hit the World Trade
Center from the street I don't know if
that played a significant role but it
played some role in me deciding that I
needed to do something sooner than later
if I wasn't completely satisfied with
what I was doing so I sold all my
possessions lived out of my car all I
did was fly I've dedicated my life since
2001 to flying paragliders for many
years I've been one the top pilots in
the US and that to me is his sign of
success watching a start of a
paragliding race of the sight to behold
100 pilots launching off the hill and
then getting up into the starting
paddock which is what we call a gaggle
the start it can be a chaotic experience
of people that are trying to get to the
top so they're in the best position so
everybody's jockeying for position
once that start that's just a glorious
experience of you know rallying through
mountain ranges for a whole day with
your friends after seven days you're
pretty exhausted but you know that's
also the the real joy in doing any kind
of endurance event just like with
anything whether you're trading socks or
riding bikes or flying paragliders
you're always trying to make progress
and increase your ability to succeed and
you know paraglide competition is a
beautiful example of pitting your skills
not only against your competitors but
against the elements
[Music]